game pass has got something for everyone
but it can also be a daunting task
trying to figure out what to play next
don't worry though we got you covered
hopefully this video will help you get a
glimpse into the next game you'll want
to check out so let's get into it
starting off with a big one
turn off the 80s metal because marvel's
guardians of the galaxy is now on game
pass developer idos montreal thrusts you
into the flying shoes of star-lord
himself where you command the rest of
the guardians in this third-person
action adventure but it ain't all
fighting and shooting this game leans
into its narrative quite heavily which
is boasted by the choice-driven dialogue
giving the players some stake in how
they unravel the story and respond to
others or
not respond at all guys
it's also directed by jean-francois duga
the director behind deus ex human
revolution and mankind divided who is a
perfect fit because like star-lord he
loves rock music but he's also an
excellent storyteller speaking of which
this game received all sorts of
accolades for its writing so even if the
action isn't totally your bag the story
could be enough to pull you in
this is one of game pass more big budget
games to come to the service and a
welcome surprise as well especially for
those who've been sleeping on this title
and if you don't want to commit to the
download you can always try it on the
cloud first
giddy up in this ruined two in western
rob weird west it's an isometric twin
stick shooter immersive sim set in a
dark fantasy western with supernatural
phenomena out the husa this is one all
about player freedom whether that's
going in guns blazin as a loyal cowboy
or robbing the bank blind to the middle
of the night and betraying everyone you
meet along the way however you want to
play the game gives you the tools to
craft your own story weird west comes
from the co-creators of dishonored and
prey which are also on game pass by the
way so you can expect the same stylized
art direction open-ended storytelling
and really cool abilities let loose in
this western sandbox
the story follows the arc of five
distinct characters each with their own
storylines and special abilities while
facing an array of enemies from regular
old bandits wildlife or things much
bigger
scarier and weirder if you're a fan of
games like fallout new vegas which is
also on game pass by the way then weird
west is highly recommended just don't
forget the most valuable cowboy advice
there ever was be rooten be too in and
by god be shootin but most of all
be kind
weird west is officially out on march
31st and is a day one game pass game so
keep an eye out this week for it
all right i'm just going to be flat out
these are some of my favorite games of
all time
zero escape the non-area games comes
with two installments in the zero escape
series nine hours nine persons nine
doors and virtue's last reward these are
escape room style visual novels that'll
completely warp your perception of the
choose your own adventure genre each
game features multiple endings filled
with fourth wall breaking counters that
left me in shock from start
to finish both of them are very dark
incredibly smart and filled with some
great puzzles but if i had to recommend
you play one of them i'd lean more
towards 9 hours 9 persons 9 doors or
more simply known as 999 not only is a
set on the titanic which for some reason
i find aesthetically very cool its
antagonist is incredibly menacing and
mysterious which is a little easier to
swallow than virtue's obnoxious rabbit
thing that's commanding you to do stuff
the entire time
just be forewarned that these games are
packed with intense themes and moments
but if that's the sort of thing that
gets you excited along with some solid
puzzles on a gripping story i cannot
recommend them enough
tunic it's a colorful vibrant isometric
action adventure that'll have you
reconstructing the game's actual
instruction manual which reveals maps
tips techniques and plenty more secrets
and really the very concept of
constructing a game's manual a lost art
of modern gaming mind you is just such a
clever concept one that tickles a sense
of nostalgia while also adding context
to the game's very design that's so cool
don't be fooled by its charming looks
however tunic can also be controller
crunchingly difficult while it has the
charm and whimsics of some zelda games
its combat and discovery is that of a
soul's like enemies have patterns each
with their own weaknesses and
devastating strengths that require you
to constantly be swift on those nimble
little paws of yours thankfully there's
accessibility options that allow the
game to be a little more approachable
like invincibility mode for example if
you're just looking to take in the
sights and discovery a welcome feature
in a notoriously unapproachable genre
when i try to explain kentucky route 0 i
usually describe it as an interactive
script for a surrealistic pop-up book
it's a whimsy trip through what can only
be described as an evolving dream at
first the story begins in the shoes of a
truck driver named conway on his way to
make a delivery along the mysterious
route zero as the story progresses
however you'll shift characters and
choose their dialogue sometimes flipping
between them mid-conversation as you go
deeper into the game you'll find
yourself falling into a beautifully
constructed tail through the winding
paths of route zero accompanied with
soft hums and moody synthesizers through
the five act journey you'll meet
memorable characters experience quirky
events and be subjected to some truly
masterful storytelling that's hard to
forget the game is unlike anything i've
ever played and its soundtrack is just
marvelous i recommend this one for fans
of coen brother movies americana
folklore and anything a little dark
moody mysterious but also lighthearted
just don't expect all your questions to
be answered however which is a-okay by
me
speaking of amazing soundtracks let me
just tell you about paradise killer real
quick it's an open world murder mystery
set on an island outside of reality
where figures larger than life reside
the game's art style is drenched in
style and originality almost as if
prince himself was resurrected as a
fantastical island and it's all set to a
base slap and city pop soundtrack
that'll ingrain itself into your noggin
after a murder occurs you lady love dies
a swab detective that was once exiled is
summoned to find the culprit among the
last residents on the island before the
island itself
dies
with the island completely open to you
from the very beginning you are allowed
to explore your own pace collect
evidence as you find it and interrogate
suspects in any order at any time you'd
like
and probably coolest of all you can
choose to initiate the trial whenever
you want so it's up to you to be as
prepared and as thorough as you want
before coming forward with the facts
it's like phoenix wright meets breath of
the wild and i am so damn here for it
this was originally exclusive to pc and
the nintendo switch so i'm really happy
to see it make its way on other consoles
with updated visuals and some extra
content as well so go play it in the
meantime i'll be listening to the song
breeze with you on repeat
[Music]
you know what maybe you don't want to
solve a crime maybe you don't want to go
on some mysterious route zero or even
try to escape a room in a sinking
titanic maybe all you want to do is
shred up the slopes
good thing they're shredders and you do
what the name says shred do sick tricks
grab your board do a spin eat sh and do
all of it in a sweet jump in shredders
this isn't like your usual ssx style
arcade snowboarding game if anything the
controls are more akin to skate where
precision pays off and the physics can
be punishing
alright this month has been a good one
for game pass between heavy hitters like
guardians of the galaxy rpgs like weird
west and then some of the more esoteric
ones like kentucky road zero there
really is something for everyone let us
know if you're checking out any of these
and if there's any you want to see in a
future installment but seriously just
just try 999 or
kentucky route 0 or
paradise killer or all of them you won't
regret it i promise alright
i'm out of here it's been great till
next time see you later
[Music]